hey youtubers has it go on hello from
VidCon I'm actually making a couple core
videos from VidCon just because it's
going through Saturday
but because book three is premiering
tonight I wanted to talk about my top
five characters that I'm looking forward
to this season almost everyone is back
from books wanted to with the exception
of the dark avatar of course just in
case you guys don't know the first
episode premieres tonight at 7:00 p.m.
Eastern Time on Nickelodeon if you're an
international person you should be able
to watch it on the website tomorrow they
usually are pretty good about streaming
episodes after they air on television
because I am at VidCon it might take me
a little bit longer to get that review
up tonight but I am starting the
giveaway whenever I post that first
review video I'll explain that at the
end of this video
be sure to subscribe to get everything
it's gonna be a lot of fun because I
don't want to spoil any big character
reveals these favorites are only gonna
include people that have appeared in the
trailers for book three just in case you
know be careful for mild book 3 spoilers
on character names so I'll give you guys
a few seconds just to get ready here we
go number 5 airbending Bumi if you
haven't seen the other core videos that
I've been doing lately you know I'm
attributing all the new airbenders to
harmonic convergence it's a timey-wimey
explanation I know but the idea is that
it changed the spiritual alignment of
the physical world before the physical
realm was very much cut off from the
spirit world but now that that isn't an
issue anymore benders are popping up all
over the place I just love the idea of
Tenzin having to teach Bumi to master
airbending it's gonna be really funny I
know but I think it's gonna bring the
children of Aang together in a way that
they weren't before during book 2 we did
see that there were a lot of like old
resentments that they had held on to
that just hadn't been dealt with until
the whole dark avatar crisis happened
now that Bumi is an airbender though he
won't have to feel like such an outsider
in his own family and Tenzin will have
the satisfaction of honoring their
father's legacy by teaching his older
brother about the family business so to
speak I know it sounds very melodramatic
but I think mostly it's gonna be used
for comedy you know in the sense of
vacation Tenzin in book 2
think of the children of aying is like
The Three Stooges although I don't quite
know which ones would be Larry Moe or
curly so that doesn't really address the
issue of kya kicking ass during the
trailer but I'll talk about that during
my review video tonight just because
Bumi will not be the only child of Annie
that'll be going through some
significant changes in book 3 number 4
both you
and old Lin beifong we saw a bunch of
Lin flashbacks in the trailer and Mike
and Brian have said for a long time that
book 3 would feature a lot of her in
present day she's going to be dealing
with her family history and in her
flashbacks it will be all about her
early life in her public city working
for her mother's police force
yay for more Toth flashbacks I don't
quite know how her family story will
weave into the main story about the evil
bending team but for the first couple of
episodes they'll probably just be
treated as separate pot lines if you
remember in the trailer we saw that
metal city that's actually the home of
the metalbending clan we'll learn all
about them on Friday but because Toph in
the idea of metal bending are so
connected in the Avatar universe I'm
totally not surprised that a metal
bending city would be part of lin
beifong's past we haven't really seen a
whole lot of our character lately and in
books 1 & 2 her story was really
confined to Republic City storylines I
know a lot of you guys who are watching
my booktube videos last year weren't a
huge fan of what was done with her
character I did feel like she was a
bigger part of the story in book 1 so
book 2 was a bit of a bummer for her but
I think a lot of the reason she wasn't
around was because that story was mostly
a Water Tribe story with unlock in the
dark avatar another there traveling to
the earth Kingdom in book 3 it's only
natural that Lin beifong will become a
much bigger part of the overstory I
remember the first time I saw Korra book
1 one of my favorite things was the
metalbending police force going all
Spider Man cables all over the city it
was a perfect example of how bending had
become more sophisticated in the 70
years since avatar last airbender to be
fair though meelo Farr bending was
probably the funniest example of that I
think the trailer scene that got me most
excited for Lin beifong in book 3 was of
her in the metal bending Academy it
wasn't a lot of context for that scene
in the trailer but it was featured in
those leaked episodes so if you want to
talk about them in the comments just
please use spoiler tags I know everyone
wants to know about the new airbending
subform but right now metal bending is
still my favorite blood bending is kind
of cool but something about metal
bending just reminds me of Full Metal
Alchemist
I'm actually hoping we get to see some
beifong metal weapon crafting I always
thought that Lin putting her armor on
and books 1 and 2 was a bit of a subtle
Iron Man reference number 3 su shi lin
beifong's half-sister based on the
information we have right now I think
suji will be the most important person
in Lin
story during book three I know all you
guys want to know about where top is but
as of right now she's still alive but
whereabouts unknown that just kind of
makes Suzy the most important person in
Lin's life by default
that doesn't mean Toph won't appear in
book three or before it just means she's
a nonentity for the time being like a
ghost that haunts Lin not a ghost in the
sense of spirits like uncle Iroh last
year though because suji storyline is
tied up in the metalbending clan we
might not meet her till after the first
couple of episodes but expect some heavy
Lin beifong drama usually when someone
like Lin never chooses to talk about her
past or her family it's because
something really bad happened
speaking of which we are gonna learn how
Lin got that scar on her face but if you
were a big fan of the Aang Republic City
flashbacks and book 1 you're gonna love
book 3 cuz there's gonna be a ton of
those but they're gonna be like very
beifong centric I'm not expecting to see
any of those until after the second or
third episode just because book three
picks up a couple months after the end
of book two so they'll still be dealing
with the aftermath of the dark avatar so
most of the first episode especially
will be spent just kind of catching up
with all the characters but number two
old man Zuko if you didn't read the
search of the promise comics you haven't
really seen Zuko since last airbender
went off the air it was said in those
stories that sometime after becoming
Fire Lord Zuko he started a family and
then passed on the title of Fire Lord to
his daughter he abdicated and started
traveling the world as an ambassador for
peace based on the trailer footage that
we've seen it seems like he's working
with the White Lotus or maybe he's been
working with them the whole time I find
it interesting that as we get closer to
book for the surviving members of the
original team avatar start manifesting
that makes me really curious if Toph is
just gonna magically appear in book 4
just because Zuko was teased for the
first two books and then appeared in
book 3 but there are so many Zuko
questions that I want answered in book 3
like one who did he end up getting
married to who's the mother of general
Iroh in the current Fire Lord like who's
his daughter and are we gonna meet her
we met I wrote back in book two and in
case you missed it he was voiced by
Dante Basco he's not going to be doing
the voice for old Zuko usually whenever
they bring Last Airbender voice actors
back they have them voice and new
characters that's why greats a Lyle is
doing the voice of that new evil
waterbender instead of doing like old
Azula her current whereabouts are
unknown even though she does resemble
sparkies
barking boom girl quite a bit based on
the footage we've seen so far it seems a
lot like Zuko story will take place
separately from chorus at least at the
start of book 3 I'm really hoping we get
to see him teach her some special
firebending techniques like remember
during booktube beginnings we saw avatar
Wan learned the dragon dance from the
dragon spirit and then we saw Zuko and
Aang learn it during last airbender
wouldn't be so cool to see him teach it
to Korra at some point I guess
technically you could argue that being
the avatar she would have had eggs
memories so if you learned something she
would have already known it typically
she only remembers things like that
whenever she accesses the avatar hard
drive and now that that's been white all
those memories are gone and the number
one character that I'm looking forward
to in book 3 is actually a four-way tie
it is basically the new evil bending
team if this were the Karate Kid movie
they'd be like Cobra Kai you know no
mercy in our dojo I'm hoping the first
or second episode introduces them all I
don't want to talk about them too much
but here are their names the firebender
sparky-sparky boom girl is paly the
waterbender is Ming hua the Airbender is
here he's actually voiced by Henry
Rollins so I'm actually really excited
about that and we don't quite know the
name of that earthbender yet they have
this really weird history with Korra
whenever she was a baby that I'm hoping
Zuko explains there's rumors that part
of book 3 will involve a plot about
controlling future avatars you know if
you could predict which bending tried
the next avatar would come from you can
influence the next avatar if you're
sneaky enough it's really unclear how
the evil bending team is going to be
tied up in this big over plot but
there's going to be so many callbacks to
the original avatar or Last Airbender
series if you're a huge fan of that you
are going to love book 3 but now it's
your turn let me know in the comments
which character are you most excited to
see in book 3 I didn't mention him in my
top 5 list but Bolin would be like my
bonus choice I'm really hoping bolin
learns to metalbend in book 3 so here's
the details on my book 3 review videos
tonight because they're airing those
first three episodes back-to-back what
i'm going to do is right up to the
episode airs i'm gonna post a combined
review of those first two episodes be
sure to subscribe to get it and then i'm
gonna post my review of episode 3 on
Saturday so I'm just gonna break those
up a little bit I'm not gonna do a Q&A
either just because that's you know
three core videos in two days I will be
giving away three
give cards for each of those three
episodes though so two in the first
review video tonight and one for the
Saturday video all you have to do to
participate in the giveaway this year is
just be a subscriber and leave a comment
on those review videos I should be able
to post my review video tonight by 9
p.m. Eastern Time but if you're worried
about missing it just follow me on
Twitter or Facebook I'm pretty good
about posting updates there
so there's links for all that at the
bottom of the description so right now
click here for that episode 1 and to
review I'll add the annotation tonight
right after I post the video and click
here for my master Korra book 3
playlists I've been doing a ton of book
3 videos so you'll be able to find all
that stuff there thanks so much for
watching I'll see you guys tonight